let's face it we are creative beings
designed to imagine and create from the
moment we arrive to this world
but somewhere along our lives we are
told to stop dreaming stop building or
tearing things apart to face reality and
get a real paying job and we lose our
creativity we go from thinking we could
be the first astronaut on mars
to feeling stuck in the hamster wheel
and end up feeling burnt out
unproductive and unmotivated
but creativity is key to our success and
happiness
you see if we were made in the image and
likeness of a creator
we are born to create
creative thinking has led to unique
designs that inspire inventions that
help improve our lives and it can change
your life
your creative energy is waiting to be
unleashed so whether or not you're
feeling stuck in an unmotivated rut
you're feeling burnt out or unproductive
or you just need some inspiration for
your creative projects i hope that this
video will be helpful for you if you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up and help support my channel but if
not by all means give it a thumbs down
but please give me some feedback in the
comments so that i know what to work on
all right let's get started number one
is to limit media consumption the first
and foremost thing that i have to say
before trying any of the other tips is
to stop that dopamine spike through
media consumption take a social media
fast stop using your phone or scrolling
through instagram the first thing you do
in the morning do yourself a favor and
stop watching the news my husband and i
recently took a trip to gatlinburg
tennessee to celebrate our anniversary
and the hotel there had the news on
every single morning at the breakfast
area we haven't had a tv in years but it
was a great reminder of why we do not
miss it because how is being reminded
that there is evil in the world supposed
to encourage and uplift my mood or how
am i supposed to feel creative and
motivated when the news or just media in
general is constantly reminding me of
all the things that could go wrong all
the people that are doing it better than
me or that i should just plain lose hope
and humanity because humans are evil
stop watching the news limit all media
as much as possible and make sure that
the media that you are consuming is
positive in nature this will make it so
that everything else that i mentioned in
this video will be much more effective
in helping you spark your creativity
number two is to write down 10 ideas
daily i started to do this about two
years ago inspired by the author james
altucher who writes in his book choose
yourself
the way you get good ideas is to do two
things
one
read two hours a day
two
write ten ideas a day
by the end of the year you will have
read for almost one thousand hours and
write down three thousand 600 ideas
one of these will be a home run
when i first began to implement this i
admit in the beginning it was not only
difficult but it felt kind of silly and
it was actually something that would
take me a while i'd sit there and think
i don't i don't know ideas about what
and it took me a while to actually start
thinking of ideas but i found that the
more i did it every single day the more
ideas i had and then pretty soon it not
only meant that i had the 10 ideas per
day i had more ideas the ideas can be
something really simple like change that
light bulb in the bathroom that you've
been meaning to do but you've been
procrastinating on or it can be
something big like for me doing a live
stream someday or having a podcast if
those ideas don't actually come to
fruition what you're doing by writing
them down is giving those ideas a place
to land so that you can actually act
towards them and possibly achieve them
doing this consistently has definitely
changed my life number two is also one
that i really love is morning pages and
this one is inspired by the author julia
cameron i've read several of her books
she is amazing but i highly recommend
the artist's way because she allowed me
to think of creativity as something that
is necessary rather than something that
i need to just push aside because i need
to be an adult and get things done but
the concept of morning pages is kind of
like a brain dump the first thing that
you do in the morning is get out a pen
and paper or a notebook or journal
whatever it is that you want to write on
and just write down whatever comes to
mind without worrying about grammar or
what your writing looks like you're just
going to write down anything that's on
your mind and the point of this is
really to bring to the surface anything
that's been bothering you and expand
upon it or expand upon ideas that you've
had or just to let go of random thoughts
and start your day off with a blank
slate i think of it as like a shower for
your brain this allows you to sift
through your thoughts so that you can be
more focused and more creative
throughout the day and personally for me
i have done this with things that kind
of bother me without going into
ruminating because that can also be
another thing in and of its own because
it allows me an opportunity to really
ask myself deeper questions of why did
this thing bother me what does this say
about me and really expand upon that and
not only understand the other person but
understand myself so it can also be
really healing while also having that
extra benefit that it really can improve
your creativity greatly number three is
both simple and powerful and that is to
do one thing differently each day what i
mean here is that if you always go to
the same restaurant order the same food
sit at the same desk talk with the same
people brush your teeth with the same
hand do things differently force
yourself to sit at a different spot than
you usually used to go through a
different route than you're usually used
to or explore a different part of that
menu that you've never tried the point
of this is to fire neural connections
and get yourself out of that autopilot
mode that you've been stuck in this
allows you with the opportunity to bring
yourself to the present because it's out
of the norm your brain is now paying
attention because this is not what it's
used to doing and just doing these
simple things differently will allow you
to take ownership of your day number
four is to try a new hobby or learn a
new skill this could be something like
taking dance lessons taking a cake
decorating class or even something that
can be completely free like having a
friend teach you how to use construction
tools or learning a new language as you
gain more experiences and learn new
skills not only will you boost your
creative energy but it will also help
you improve your confidence and this
alone will go a long way towards
increasing your motivation number five
is immensely important and that is to
read books or listen to audiobooks i did
mention that you should limit media
consumption as much as possible but one
of my favorite things to do on idle time
which is that time when you're doing
something mindlessly like washing the
dishes for example is to listen to
audiobooks this allows me a time to
focus on learning and processing new
information i have several videos on the
topic of reading and its importance
which i can link down below but what i
have found that works best for me is to
use audiobooks when i'm doing things
that don't really require much thought
like cleaning the house for example and
then reading a physical book before
going to bed some people prefer to read
in the morning and that's perfectly fine
too just find what works best for you
but in any case reading is like gold
when it comes to developing
life-changing habits and boosting
creative thinking number six is to spend
time with positive or inspiring people
if you're like me from a few years back
and your conversations looked like this
hey so i got this great idea of starting
the youtube channel why would you do
that you know growing a youtube channel
is so hard these days it is so saturated
and you don't even have social media how
is it going to grow you're just
basically going to be working for free
for years i wouldn't bother if every
time you think of a new idea or decide
to try something different the people
around you only bring up the negative
points it may be time to get some more
positive influences
number seven is to watch your health i
recently shared with you my experience
with the keto diet but eliminate sugars
and processed foods from your diet okay
i know what you may be thinking what the
heck does my diet have to do with
creative thinking everything the food
that you eat directly impacts your
hormone balance your mood your physical
energy your sleep your health in general
if you physically feel crappy it's gonna
be pretty darn hard to do mundane tasks
let alone creative projects so
prioritize your health this is a must
number eight don't be so serious
make time to play and laugh science has
shown that the physiological effect of
smiling actually makes us happy through
the release of endorphins happy hormones
they reduce stress can boost your mood
and can in turn help you access that
creative power within you i love the
quote by james altucher in his book
reinvent yourself today i will try again
and tomorrow and then the next day if i
don't get better i will at least have
fun trying and what else is there in
life but to play as much as possible
number nine is one of my absolute
favorites is to spend time in nature if
you live in a very populated city you
will know that people are often in a
rush aggressive drivers are never in
shortage and the atmosphere is just go
go go my husband and i personally love
hiking and being out in nature and we
actually crave it when we've been in the
city a little more than we would like
because nature is just healing we get so
used to reacting to buzzes and beeps and
lights all day long that we become
desensitized to our surroundings and we
lose the ability to be still be present
and be in the moment to really take
things in like seeing a butterfly on a
bush
a squirrel passing by or feeling how
small we are on this huge earth when we
see a beautiful landscape spending some
time in nature will no doubt help you
slow down the pace so that you can focus
on living rather than doing and lastly
number 10 travel even remotely traveling
doesn't have to mean that you have to
pack up a suitcase and go across the
country it can be as simple as a weekend
road trip to visit nearby states or
taking the afternoon to visit a town
that you haven't explored whatever the
case may be return to your childlike
self again and find the explorer within
you that's it for today's video i hope
that you found it helpful and please
don't forget to give it a thumbs up and
subscribe for more videos on all things
living a simpler happier healthier life
thanks so much for watching until next
time
[Music]
you